joining us now with reaction to What has
been a very busy Newsweek Harvard Law
Professor Alan dershowitz and South
Carolina Congresswoman Nancy mace as
well as Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett there's a lot to unpack here I
know it can seem like so many different
pieces Greg we'll start with you when it
comes to what is being investigated and
what is not and about presidential AIDS
but aren't we looking here especially
when we think about the pseudonyms this
was a dynamic when the when Biden was
vice president conducting official
business under an assumed name with a
government account and what is the say
Greg when it comes to what else may be
happening and frankly what is Biden
doing now is that is that a behavior
that you stop utilizing no it's not and
if Joe Biden was using aliases to funnel
privileged government information to his
son who was then handing it off to his
uh foreign business partners his benefit
actors lavishing tens of millions of
dollars on him then it simply
underscores the Biden family corruption
and Joe Biden's direct complicity in his
son's influence peddling schemes which
are defined in the criminal codes as
bribery you know we already know from
Devin Archer that the bidens were
selling access to Joe and Promises of
influence and you don't have to under
the law show that Joe Biden uh was paid
a penny of it the law says if it goes to
another person or entity such as shell
companies it's still bribery and Joe
Biden doesn't have to deliver on any of
the promises though he did so for
barisma because the promise itself is
bribery under the criminal codes Under
the statutes an extraordinary time
congresswoman mace you're on the
oversight committee lots of
Investigations about Hunter but in a way
it really hasn't been about Hunter right
this is the step the first step on a
Stairway that when we're looking at the
involvement of the senator the vice
president now president is this
significant to you that we're finding an
effort by Joe Biden to evade detection
with certain Behavior
oh it's huge and when you look at the
lies that he's told over the last couple
of years denial of everything it just
corroborates the information we've
already collected and if you look at
what the mainstream media on the left is
doing they're saying that all of this is
perfectly normal but the average
American knows it's anything but and on
the oversight committee I want to see
every single Aid associated with Joe
Biden every single business partner
business associate associated with the
Biden family every single witness
subpoenaed to come before the oversight
committee and give their testimony
because none of this is adding up and
the average American knows that it's not
and we're not allowed to share for
example the suspicious activity reports
because they're confidential but Tammy
if I could share the amount of money
that we're talking about in money
laundering it is astronomical it would
blow your mind to know that the amount
of money that we're talking about here
that was laundered through dozens and
dozens of shell companies none of this
happens without job Biden and it ought
to be investigated the fullest extent of
the law referred charges and we ought
not to see the doj FBI and IRS continue
to obfuscate and obstruct our
investigation and I know that the
American people they have very little
trust and faith in Congress we haven't
given them given them much reason to but
trust the evidence that comes out of our
committees and make their decision
themselves over the next couple of
months the next year or so on whether or
not this guy should be president on
whether or not the tens of millions
north of 50 million I would argue that
he sold out his country for to our
adversaries none of it's adding up yeah
Professor dershowitz I mean we perhaps
one of the little bit of a statement
that this you know has been going on
forever or is normal in a way could be
true right you've got Hunter Biden's
lawyer I think it was Abby Lowell saying
that all of this is too complicated to
explain and people have been doing this
for Millennia well people have been
doing a lot of bad things for thousands
of years it doesn't mean that we should
accept it as normal do you see this as
something that is suddenly going to you
know break this wall of what seems to be
Biden corruption for perhaps as far as
we know maybe even up to 50 years his
entire career is this normal for
Washington and are we just finding out
well it pains me to say this because I
like Joe Biden I've known him for 40
years I'd like to vote for him in the
next election but the time has come to a
point an independent outside special
counsel to investigate the relationship
between Hunter Biden and President Biden
there's already a special Counsel on the
classified material but that's totally
different in fact if I were Joe Biden I
would be calling for a special counsel
to take this case out of partisan House
of Representatives
to bring it to somebody who is beyond
any reproach a great you know former
president of the University dean of a
law school uh somebody who can look at
this thing it's very it is very
complicated and you need to look at it
with a totally clear objective eye the
allegations are serious but the evidence
has to back up the allegations and a
special outside Council uh couldn't do
this you know in my book I wrote a book
about this called get Trump I call for
uh an independent special counsel
balanced on all sides I'm not rooting
for anybody here I want to see full and
equal justice done I want to see
everything that's happening on one side
happening on the other and I think that
a special counsel at this point
advocated previously but at this point
enough there to appoint a special
independent Council and it should be
somebody who has the approval of
Republicans and Democrats alike well see
that that of course would be the thing
to do but because they aren't looking
for a solution or a real investigation
Greg is why that's not happening of
course that's the normal thing to do
what would be the right thing to do Greg
isn't the point of all of this to just
delay because they've been able to do it
from the start with Trump they're able
to move things through and they want you
know trials in two months and they want
it all done by a certain date you know
they got a fire lit under them but but
in this case it's they want to have no
fire it seems like that's you know
what's manifesting here it's a cover-up
and it's a protection Racket and Mara
Garland has now doubled down on it by
appointing the last person in the world
who should be special counsel uh David
Weiss I mean this is the guy who allowed
statute of limitations to run during the
course of his five-year investigation
tipped off Hunter Biden's lawyers ripped
up an agreement by investigators and
prosecutors uh to charge six serious
felonies against Hunter Biden which
would have implicated Joe Biden as
complicit in the schemes this is the guy
you know who scuttled search warrants I
mean the list goes on and on about his
political
interference and he will not experience
some sudden Epiphany and decide to do
the right thing and file the charges
that are merited I'd rather bet on a
lame horse congresswoman may you know
people have been discussing Jonathan
Turley sir Andy McCarthy I think
everyone here how that appointment of
Weiss himself is you know against the
regulations when we look to Congress
we're thinking is is there no recourse
to this is is there something that can
be done with this being so obviously
political or do you think that
congress's hands are tied I mean what
what can the American people expect when
it comes to action to at least push back
with some of this stuff
well we know that the oversight
committee we're going to push forward
we're going to continue our
investigation Our concern today is that
the appointment of David Weiss is going
to slow down the investigation that is a
very realistic concern we've already
seen before David Weiss's appointment
we've seen the FBI and doj slow down
their responses when we've sent in
inquiries it took us months to get the
11023 document which showed by the way
the ukrainians barisma executives were
so proud of all the layering and
complicated ways they funneled money to
bribe Hunter and Joe Biden they said it
would take the U.S government 10 years
to figure out where the money came from
and where it went we know where it went
on the back pocket of Joe Biden but they
may create a very complicated system
that has been slowed down by allies of
Joe Biden it'll slow the oversight it
can be down but we're still going to
push forward you know Professor you'd
think people think that Congress has
some power and can you know tell Biden
that they're not going to pass certain
things they can stop the approval of of
nominees and of Judges isn't there
something that you would suggest that
Professor dershowitz that could actually
get some motion going here so that
there's some kind of a a back and forth
about what's appropriate
well it's important to have congress
serve as a check and balance on the
executive but when you have two people
running for president essentially this
is at this point a two-person race and
one of them Donald Trump has special
counsel for indictments interfering with
his campaigning you have to lean over
backwards to make sure that the other
candidate is treated equally even if
it's a close question a special counsel
should be appointed in the case of the
current president of the United States
in order to level the playing field in
order to make sure that the public
doesn't perceive this as unequal justice
as different standards on one side than
the other yeah so I don't know how will
come out but if I were Joe Biden I would
say Bring It On actually if he's
innocent bring it on special counsel
will help me because it will be neutral
and objective yes
that's what we want and clearly I think
we're we would all agree that we're not
exactly there the Democratic party is
going to have to step up if they want to
have some kind of normal you know
normalcy uh in the process of all of
this happening uh thank you all
congresswoman mace allender schwitz Greg
Jared I appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else